at camden yards in baltimore the new
york mets playing the baltimore orioles
nets haven't been in baltimore in a
couple of years
they'll try and fire the cannon tonight
maybe eat a few crabs along the way yes
it's baltimore camden yards is the scene
they'll take their swings off of asher
wojciechowski making his seventh start
he's one and three
with a 5.13 era 26 in the third he's
punched out 24
walked 10 and the key for wojo get out
of the first
inning that's always his toughest inning
and get the first out of every inning
that's going to be a key for him
as well last time the mets came to
camden yards
brandon nimmo had himself a show
slapped on the ground through the open
hole and into left field and nemo starts
another series at camden yards with a
hit now eight for nine
in his last three games in this ballpark
michael conforto having
a good year for him bounce to the left
side ruiz the second
for one on to first they turn two that's
a nice helper for
any pitcher who has trouble getting out
of the first inning right wipe out two
with one pitch
and there is arielle gerardo set to make
his mets debut that's picked up harado
for cash and a player to be named later
on august the 5th and now four weeks
later getting a start
iglesia is always a gifted fielder but
having himself a
revelatory year with the baton
right center field hit well and that is
down for a base hit
mullins racing into third iglesia slides
in with a double
you know what else he knows how to do
too he knows how to hit yes
and he has done that all year for the
orioles came in hitting 405.
that's a nine-game hitting streak now
with the orioles second
and third now with just one out here in
the first so now nunez
the chance to drive in a couple here's
the one-two hit well center field way
back
at the wall it's out of here nunez with
a three-run shot to get the orioles
started in the first
number eight on the year for renato let
it fly young fellow
i mean he went up to get this one up in
the zone to get it
two-strike count are not though nunez
straight away
center field so the mets have a lead-off
hit for the second straight inning
nemo was erased in a double play in the
first now jeff mcneal who had an
encouraging day at the plate yesterday
with a pair of doubles
that's pulled down the right field line
by mcneil and that's a fair ball
bouncing
into the corner it stays in play canoe
goes to third
and mcneil pulls in at second base with
a double
so mcneil after two doubles yesterday as
his eighth double of the year the mets
of second and third and nobody out
so second and third and nobody on a
chance for alonso to get the mets right
back
in it and alonso flies it to center
field
coming over as mullins in a right center
tagging at third as cano
canoe comes home the throw goes to third
and the mets ever run on the board
so alonso gets a run in with a sacrifice
fly
his 19th run bad at the end of the year
and that cuts the baltimore lead to
three to one
guillermo starting at third base for the
second straight day
2-2 to george and the breaking ball hit
up the middle of base head mcneil around
30 is going to be waved home
mullen's throw goes to second so luis
guillory comes through with an rbi
single and the mets are back to within a
run it's now three to two
so second and third and one out and
anthony santon
santander comes up and a base hit into
right field
malaika scores velazquez will be held at
third
and the orioles tack on another run and
go on top 4-2
so now they're on the corners first and
third still only one out
bounce down to third to second for one
that's all they'll get
and the orioles tack on another run and
go up 5-2
robinson canoe is pros pro no question
about that
singleton scored his first time
canoe hits one on the air to deep right
field headed toward the wall
and it's out of here robinson canoe with
a base at his first time up and now his
seventh home run of the year
and canoe who we mentioned loves sitting
at camden yards gets the mets back
closer it's now five to three so two on
the runner at first and now andres
jimenez who has struck
on flight out over two and he's the
tying run he flies this one out to left
pretty well hit mount castle back
and it's out of here andres jimenez with
his first
major league home run he goes the other
way to tie the game
a two-run shot for jimenez and it's five
to five in the sixth
two for two average up to 256 for pat
valleca
3-1 pitch that's hitting the gap
around third is ruiz he'll score easily
and pat vallejo with an rbi double
three for three for pat felika
having himself a night now he goes to
work on anthony santander
tony deep right center nobody's gonna
catch this one
it is god wow santander with a bullet
over the medstar health sign
two run shot his 11th of the year and
the orioles go up
eight to five renato nunez steps in
2-2 there it goes way back
and out of here second homer of the game
for renato nunez and there's another
tack on right nunez cooking tonight home
run number nine
here's michael conforto fly ball let's
hit well
back on the track and making the catch
is ryan montcastle that'll do it
gave it a ride but not enough and the
orioles win the opener
of this two-game series 9-5